Pour ne louper aucune vidéo,
abonnez-vous et activez la petite cloche !
Salut les Épicurieux.
Connaissez-vous l'originede l'expression
"prendre des mesures draconiennes" ?
Prendre des mesures draconiennes.
Autrementdit des mesures d'une sévérité exemplaire
qui ne souffrent aucune exception.
Mais d'où sort lequalificatif
"draconien" ?
Du nom d'un personnage grec
qui vivait au septième siècle
avantnotre ère.
Un dénommé
Dracon
avec un "C".
Alors que la cité est en proie à la guerre civile
etqu'il faut ramener le calme,
ce monsieur est chargé de remettre
un peu d'ordre dans les lois du moment.
Il faut dire qu'à l'époque
le droit n'est pas écrit.
Il est rendu par des magistrats qui interprètent
des coutumes transmises oralement
et décident bien souvent à la tête du client et
en fonction de leurs intérêts.
Pour assurer la paix sociale,
Dracon doit mettre les choses noirsur blanc
et définir une peine correspondant
à chaque infraction.
Seules quelques bribes de cestextes
nous sont parvenues
mais il semble
qu'il n'y soit pas allé avec le dos de la cuillère.
Apparemment Dracon considérait
que toutes les infractions perturbaient l'ordre public
de lamême manière
et valaient donc
la même peine
en l'occurrence
la peine de mort.
D'où le caractèresévère et stricte
d'une mesure draconienne.